now one of the big changes that's
happened recently in markets isn't just
with currencies it's with mortgage rates
and I'm going to show you what people
have been expecting to happen to Bank of
England interest rate and what's changed
over the course of the last few months
this is a kind of a chart looking into
the future and what you see is that's
where bank rate is at the moment 2.25
and back in August the expectation among
Traders out there in the marketplace was
it was going to Peak at about 2.75 next
year of course A lot has changed since
then
um in fact it's gone up to 4.75
expectations in September and then came
the midi budget and look at that line up
to 5.5 that's actually down a little bit
on where it was last week it was about
6.1 percent last week now all of that is
already starting to feed through to the
mortgage offers that we are getting
around the marketplace so have a look at
this this shows you the average two-year
mortgage rate uh on offer and this is
the kind of average going all the way
back to 2008 and that's where it was
only a few months ago look at where that
line has gone up to now so that's now up
to a
6.07 percent now that's the highest
level that we've seen for that two-year
average since 2008 okay so the highest
since 2008 but here's what really
matters now you've got to bear in mind
that back in 2008 we were slightly less
indebted than we are now and when you
adjust for that and look at a kind of
different measure the mortgage repayment
burden now this is the mortgage burden
okay the higher this line is the more of
our incomes we're having to pay on
mortgage repayments on any new deals and
look at what's happened recently you can
see that earlier on only about a couple
of months ago it got up to the highest
level that it been since 2008 but since
then it's got even higher up to the
highest level since the late 1980s early
1990s and this is the real concern at
that rate that we're seeing right now in
the marketplace you are seeing the
highest level of repayments that we've
seen since a period when the UK was
about to face the biggest housing crash
it ever faced before that's the big
concern both politically and
economically for the conservative party
that this cost of living crisis is also
going to become potentially a mortgage
crisis